وزير الخارجيه الروسيه الولايات المتحده
باستهداف منظمه اسيان والسعي لاستبدالها
وعلى هامش المنتدى الاقليمي السنوي لدول
رابطه اسيان قال لابروفين واشنطن تريد
اقحام النيتو في المنطقه بحسب تعبيره
نتعرض لتحديات عديده في اسيان لان
الولايات المتحده وحلفائها يريدون استبدال
منظومه اسيان التي تطورت خلال عشرات
السنوات باستراتيجيه المحيط الهادئ
والهندي وادخال النيتو في هذه المنطقه وقد
تمت الاشاره الى ذلك في قمه النيتو بمدريد
والامين العام للحلف قال ان هذا الامر
يتعلق بالامن العالمي كما انهم من المخطط
نقل البنيه التحتيه العسكريه الى استراليا
ونيوزيلندا واليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه ومن
المرجح ان اليابان سترحب بنشر الاسلحه
الامريكيه النوويه وهو ما اعتقد انه نهج
خطير للغايه ولقد تحدثنا مع زملائنا في
اسيان عن هذا الموضوع